peter schrager here on the rich eisen
show from good morning football and fox
sports how are you peter did i nail that
did i did i
kind of stick the the landing on john
schneider's two cents on the subject
or am i off kind of you did a good job
and dr melfi's a great reference to the
greatest television show to ever hit the
airwaves
um i i'll tell you you know i spoke with
sources in chicago
and the feeling i get is almost like we
didn't ask for this
their agent named us that's when we got
involved like
the bears have this have this thing
where mark rogers the agent tells adam
schefter
that chicago is one of the teams and the
bears pounced immediately
and left us think that the bears didn't
go for this you're right rich there's
nothing they can do they didn't have a
quarterback
they could offer but they offered just
about everything else i'll tell you that
i don't have all the details but i've
spoken with folks in chicago and let's
just say
they came to the table with what they
could offer and at the end of the day
you know they were all in fargo together
john schneider ryan pace matt maggie
there were conversations being had
they were there for trey lance's uh pro
day last week
and unfortunately for bears fan russell
wilson wasn't being traded
and so to the fans who are like ah we
got it we should never have dropped the
phone well
you know it'd be nice to have josh allen
too you can't just trade for josh allen
it'd be nice for mahomes too you can't
just trade for them
so they went down the list and winston
was a conversation
look he's already got sean payton's eye
and he's a year into sean payton's
system that made sense for both of them
uh ryan fitzpatrick they looked at you
hey 38 years old never been to a playoff
game
i don't know is that an upgrade from
dawn and they went through it with alex
smith and the rest and it was like
here's andy dalton
33 years old can still throw the
football
he's not going to hurt you he might not
win you many games with his arm but he's
certainly not going to lose you many
games with his arm
let's roll the dice for a one year deal
but gosh you know
i wanted the russell wilson thing to
happen too if i'm a bears fan it just
wasn't and unfortunately
this really was all started by russell
wilson's camp even putting chicago out
there
so i guess you're you know because that
was my next question
uh and you you you kind of answered it
with the plan b
because you know when you said fargo it
did jump out at me like you know
that the bears fans are kind of viewing
them like jerry lundergaard trying to
scratch out the vin numbers to
to throw off the scent on exactly how
this all
started you know what i mean and so um
the plan b is now i guess to go run off
to the hotel to try and escape the
the nfl bears fans police by saying andy
dalton's our our best option
is that truly their only best option i
mean like what was their plan going into
the off season fully no i mean like you
could see the writing on the trubisky
wall
way back even to last year's training
camp where they were hoping foles was
going to push him
so what was the plan before mark rogers
did open his mouth
to schefter to say we'll we'll we'll go
to chicago i mean
what about that one yeah i think that's
fair
and i think andy dalton might have been
on the top hit list even then
truth they decided last year that
trubisky
was going to have a one-year opportunity
to prove himself they didn't pick up the
option
they could have done what the eagles did
and signed wence to
a hundred million dollar deal and then
be kicking themselves and having to
trade him 60 cents on the dollar
two years later they could have done
what the rams did and kind of put
lipstick on a pig here and said look we
got stafford but you also did sign golf
two years ago to that hundred million
dollar deal
but there's one against the grain didn't
sign trubitsky without a big deal
they're probably happy they didn't sign
tribute to that deal
and the way the cards fell the darnold
trade wasn't happening
i don't even know if they explored him
so cam newton wasn't happening i'm not
even sure that was an option
but they looked at this off season and
said okay there's going to be some
quarterback options let's see what we
can do unfortunately for them
they went to the playoffs and they have
the 20th overall pick
so they can't just say it's going to be
trey lance it could be justice and field
so the best option that they believe
that was still currently on the table
was andy dalton look they're not doing
flips right now they're excited to have
a new quarterback and they think they
can win with ann dalton because of how
good their defense is and because what
they're building and that
dalton is a formidable nfl quarterback
but sure they understand this isn't one
that the fan base necessarily going to
be doing parades over
and uh you know the fargo reference and
the [ __ ] the shami and francis mcdormand
all that
you know i'm picturing them in the snow
kind of like with the footprints in the
snow and just
kind of getting through this but who
knows a year from now we could be
looking at this and saying
either a dalton went 10-6 and the
defense is really good and look they're
back to what they were a couple years
ago
or could be looking at hey they're 5-11
and matt nagy
maybe isn't the quarterback whisperer we
thought because here's another
quarterback that couldn't get it done
i i think they know the time is up and
they know what time it is and
for them andy dalton is who they're
putting their eggs in the basket with
what do you peter schrager here on the
rich eisen show what do you what do you
think um
and again i i i i hesitate to do this
but i'm going to do it anyway
and my hesitation is from andy dalton
deserves better uh
i said in uh to lead the show one of the
things i said
was that dalton deserves the the foals
sort of uh
baptism by the football gods to just go
on a run for his career and just be able
to say
yeah i got it done um because he
deserves all the hard work that he's
made himself into and what he and his
wife have done charitably
charitable works-wise i mean he he
totally deserves
anything uh about kind of the treatment
i'm about to give him
what do you think the packers are
thinking today peter
yeah look here's the thing with andy
dalton to your point on on andy
great pro you've probably interviewed
him more than a dozen times and
you know it must mean he's a pretty good
player when he's interviewing with rich
eisen on the thursday night set
probably a handful of times means he's
won a lot of games in his career
and you know i spoke to someone who's
coached andy dalton they said okay he's
getting
lambasted right now he's getting made
fun of and you know last
yesterday i'm watching nfl network that
we both work on and steve smith's on
there saying that the bears are the big
winners of free agency because it means
it guarantees them
you know a top five pick next year and
they're gonna finally get another chance
at a quarterback because that's how bad
they're gonna be
but it's a line and it's funny and we
smirk but it's like
dawn's a proud man remember this is a
guy who was a second round pick
won a rose ball at tcu over wisconsin
went on and won the job in cincinnati
went to the playoffs
and has been overlooked his entire
career this is what i i got from a
person who's coached him and i thought
it was
something i wouldn't be able to say
unless you know someone with
knowledge because andy doll's been a
redhead guy his entire life
and he's been picked on since he was a
kid he's always been the red-headed
quarterback he's always been
looked at as this like wow here's this
red-headed dude in the room of all these
and he's always come out as being the
alpha in the room and he's always found
a way to win
and he's been fighting haters his entire
career this is no different
he's gonna thrive there so i know we
don't look at andy dalton as like the
tom brady type where it's a sixth round
pick and i've been overlooked and i'm
gonna
keep that on the chip on my shoulder and
the whole thing
but there might be something to that and
if players all seem to like playing for
him
and the coaches all love coaching for
him and he's now the joke of the nfl all
of a sudden andy dalton's the joke of
the nfl with all his playoff appearances
maybe he internalizes that and maybe
this ends up being
andy dalton in the redemption season
that we've been waiting that's why i'm
saying he deserves it peter but the fact
is that he isn't aaron rodgers and he
isn't tom brady and those are the two
teams that played in the nfc
championship game and if the bears want
to get where they want to go with a
coach and a general manager that's
hanging on
by a thread then how does this move
actually work and bears fans are
absolutely
right to go absol to to have a major
problem with the direction of this team
fully knowing that brady's about to run
it back
and that's why i asked how the packers
are feeling because they sign aaron
jones and
at least we we know we're thinking
they're not going to draft a quarterback
or running back with their first round
pick they're going to get better
they're actually going to start adding
to this offense that has tonyan that has
a defense that they are going to
reconfigure with a new defensive
coordinator that's why i asked you what
the packers are thinking today
yeah packers are probably thinking we're
in good shape because we've been 13-3
the past two years
we've got aaron rodgers at quarterback
but i'll tell you what
they weren't doing any you know aaron
jones is a good deal we'll see
those numbers by the way still haven't
been reported fully we'll see what he
ends up making there
but by choosing aaron jones they had to
let cory lindsey walk and i know this
isn't
a fantasy football player but he's an
all-pro first-team
center right and he just got paid the
most money ever by a center by the
chargers
and if you're aaron rodgers you want all
your guys back and you want aaron jones
and you want damonte adams well
getting your center back would have been
great too so every team is dealing with
this right now and no bigger issue than
the quarterback in chicago i understand
that
but here's the packers and aaron rodgers
just lost his all-pro center
a couple years after losing gulaga and
guess what shaq bear attacked him three
times in the nfc championship game so
everyone got issues if you're not in
tampa i think you're feeling the pain
the heat right now including green bay
peter schrager here on the rich eisen
show so other than uh belichick creating
bill coin is a cryptocurrency
this free agency and also uh this story
in chicago what are the stories of free
agency so far as we celebrate the new
league year officially and everything
that we've heard about over the last
several weeks from matthew stafford to
the rams and golf to the
lions uh all the way to the present day
becomes official what's the story
do you think peter yeah i think the wide
receivers is an interesting deal right
now rich because
here was a market that we knew was going
down
and yet to not have any of the big name
wide receivers get any money yet
and i don't think they're going to get
top dollar tells me that there was a
market
um that might have been expected by some
of their agents that that
doesn't exist because i know a lot of
these guys and i'll say kenny goliday to
start
was offered a deal midway through the
year that i think if he was to be
presented with right now would probably
accept
um juju smith schuster says i'm gonna go
hit free agency let's
go break the bank um the money's not
there right now
and i'm trying to piece it together
talking to a lot of teams saying is it
because the wide receivers just aren't
truly number one guys gallaudet and
schuster and curtis samuel
or is it something about the actual
position
and the fact that there are receivers
coming out in the draft every year if
you can get in the first second or third
round
and it could be george jefferson or
justin jefferson or it could be aj brown
or it could be dk metcalf and the answer
is
it's both of those things and it's a
freaking pandemic
our salary cap is way down and no one
expected it to be a year ago when they
were saving up all their money
to see how we look towards the future so
cash rushers they're always going to get
paid
past protectors are always going to get
paid quarterbacks are always going to
get paid
unfortunately wide receivers which
usually always get paid
are not getting paid and i'm curious to
see if all these guys end up signing
one-year deals and are back on the
market next year so you're saying
wide receivers of the new running back
pretty much florida
that's what it looks like i mean think
about it think about it
you know especially it's interesting
because staphon digs
delivered right and deandre hopkins
delivered but you look at a juju or you
look at a kenny gallaudet or a curtis
samuel or even a t
y hilton will fuller they're not they're
not stefan diggs
they're not ken they're not going to be
deandre hopkins so then what is that
next class and what am i worth in the
past
salary cap is going up up up up someone
will pay for them
and they'll figure it out they'll be a
jaguar and they'll you know whatever and
we'll figure it out
this year teams were just like no i'm
not spending money on wide receiver
so we always said uh mamas teach your
children to be quarterbacks
and not to be running backs maybe not
wide receivers either peter schrager
here on the rich eisen show i know
you're tight with uh robert sala
and the jets hold all the cards right
now cause um
it's a trevor lawrence jacksonville
jaguar urban meyer marriage
and then so now we're looking at two and
the decision that the jets make there
um is crucial because if they take the
rookie then who gets darnold if they
stick with donald who gets the rookie
and then of course
whatever the heck is going on in houston
with deshaun watson and the texans and
the city of houston
um makes that a completely potentially
turbulent situation
so what are we now that we're beginning
to get through the
first rush of free agency what is that
crucial decision that the jets are going
to make
uh look like right now yeah no rich it's
fascinating because
you know ian rapp ports on our network
on nfl network and chapters on espn and
the report is that
you know they haven't made their
decision yet i gotta be honest with you
they have been i've spoken to them
they're like we're still doing the work
on the quarterbacks and joe douglas went
out to north dakota
to see trey lance in person he'll be out
at byu's pro day to see zach wilson in
person
the number two pick you hope to never
have the number two pick in the next 20
years or at least in your gm
tenure you think that if there's a
quarterback that blows you away and is
like
this guy's going to be an all-pro this
guy's got joe burrow or
george or herbert quality all right
let's take him with the number two
overall pick because
the thing with darnold is he's going to
hit free agency next year
or you got to pick up his option and the
situation there is
okay say he goes eight and eight are we
any more certain on darnold than we were
this offseason or if he goes nine and
seven does that mean we're giving him a
hundred million dollars to be our
quarterback
so they've got a lot of decisions to
make i think the big x factor
is how much they love this zach wilson
and if they love him at all
i know that salah likes sam darnold
that was what he said on the initial
outfit when he first came on i know that
organization
loves sam darnold he's done nothing but
represent them to the best of his
greatest fighting
despite some real negative things and
the adam gates factor
is real that ryan tannehill went on to
be a
really good pro bowl level quarterback
once he left adam gays
and ended up in tennessee with a new
system so the question is
once you leave adam gates and donald now
joins the mike lafleur kyle shanahan
system
is he suddenly going to be a pro bowl
style quarterback these are decisions
they have to make
the zack buzz is real teams like him
there's a lot to like
but he didn't play against any
competition either this past season
and about uh 18 months ago he was in a
three-person race to be the quarterback
at byu
so he's no short thing very interested
done though
but i say they won't have their answer
until they at least see zach wilson on i
believe march 31st
so uh if joe douglas was at trey lance's
pro day in north dakota
does he go up to ryan pace and john
schneider when they're taught hey what
are you guys talking about you know
uh what do you you know uh
john i mean uh if you're talking to ryan
um you want your
uh your first round pick back with just
sam darnold uh you know and just
throw that out there any word if he did
anything like that
peter not a bad idea and and i'll tell
you that that fargo thing was
interesting was the first time
that all these gm's were actually
together 30 different teams
presented at trey lance's pro day and it
was right before free agency and i can
tell you
they had unfettered access to each other
so you know it's a tampering window you
got to be careful with free agents but
if i want to talk about making a
possible trade i haven't seen you in
person in over 16 months or whatever it
is
there's no combine i can finally get a
chance to put you aside
from what i know there were no
conversations and darnold wasn't
shopped exclusively or at all at that
pro day but
like i always say the phone lines are
open until
until they're not so operators standing
by
operators standing by and so what is the
deal with desean watson right now
peter we had mike lombardi on yesterday
he said
he's here and he wants no part of the
afc east teams he wants denver he wants
san francisco and then san francisco is
just
fascinating with jimmy garoppolo and
what may happen and here's the new
league year starting and we haven't
heard a thing about garoppolo
what do you got for me on that right now
yeah well i don't know if this has been
reported yet i didn't say it on our show
but i've heard from
secondary sources that the niners were
actually looking at andy dalton also and
the question is
were they looking at andy dalton to be a
backup or are they looking at andy
dalton to be a starter and if that's
even on their radar when they have josh
rosen
and jimmy garoppolo what does that tell
you about jimmy so if they were
interested at all in andy dalton maybe
it is just to be a backup to jimmy
because he gets
injured so often right i think that
leaves the door open but gosh can you
imagine desean watson and kyle
shanahan's offense it would be amazing
so yeah they had trent williams it all
makes sense but
remember they were sniffing around on
brady last year and they
essentially were like yeah we're gonna
sit with you garoppolo and go to war
with the guy who got the super bowl
they're going
big splash for brady so i you know jimmy
is always fascinating there because yet
again he missed 10 games last season
we really have only one year a 16-game
season where he took him to the super
bowl
that we're basing it on but this is
really the final year of his whole
contract deal so
if they roll with them this is probably
a break for jimmy
san francisco and if they don't i would
not be surprised at all if they made
some big move
peter thanks for the call appreciate it
let's do this a lot more often over the
next few weeks as we get closer to that
draft in ohio where so much
could happen on that first night of the
draft oh my goodness
it's really shaping up to be big i
appreciate the time as always
cannot wait and rich for your honor and
because of our friendship i have taken
jawan howard in the michigan wolverine
to win it all in my bracket how long are
we
how good are you normally picking your
back bracket peter
terrible i always go with zinzaga and
they lose in the second round
ah peter thanks for the call i
appreciate it and the confidence
thank you so much you're the man right
back at you that's peter schrager at p
on uh on twitter i follow him you should
as well
at gmfb as well hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here